hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
on my Nexus 6 I have the latest version
of Android Android M the Developer
Preview what is the M stand for usually
the easiest way to find that out is to
just go to the easter-egg and tap the
logo a bunch and whatever reigns down is
what it stands for so an Android L when
you tap that logo a bunch lollipops rain
down Android lollipop
an Android M when you tap that logo a
bunch it just kind of shrugs at you so
we don't have a name for it yet maybe
leave a comment of what you think the
name is going to be my bet is on
milkshake so Android M is not a huge
update by any means it's more of a 5.2
update with a focus on polish and
clarity and it's mostly just a ton of
tweaks that's got a couple of new
features and tricks up its sleeve here
and there but this could mostly be a top
five tweaks video so the number five
best feature is volume controls and this
might seem like a little thing because
it is but it's been wrong for so long in
stock Android that it's awesome to
finally see it here and it's been so
obvious that other manufacturers have
built it into their skins correctly when
in google's it's been wrong now you can
hit the volume down button all the way
down to zero volume and get to silent
mode and then you can't volume down
again to get to do not disturb mode and
there's also a little cog to expand to
have different separate MIDI controls
for media volume or ringtone volume or
notification volume finally is right
again and it should have been this way
the whole time number four is
fingerprint reading is now built in
natively into Android and what this
means is you can now log into your
device using your fingerprint you can
buy apps from the Play Store with your
fingerprint and you can even use Android
pay with your fingerprint and also this
is a wide open API as you would expect
from something from Google so what that
means you'll not only encourage more
manufacturers to build a fingerprint
reader into their phone but also you
encourage more application makers to
build in fingerprint reading into their
app so in any app where you might buy
something like your banking app or any
other in-app purchase you can use your
fingerprint number three I would
classify as all these little tweaks a
bunch of the little things some of them
are visual like the lockscreen has a
little bit of a different looking clock
that looks a bit better now but some of
them are functional too so the quick
settings get it do not disturb toggle
right there you can also now control the
individual permissions
for every app so if you want the
Facebook app for example to no longer
have access to your microphone and your
camera you can turn those off
individually so very nice security
features that I think a lot of people
are going to take advantage of copy and
paste now automatically selects forward
word by word which is awesome and easy
you can now make a portable hotspot
that's 2.4 gigahertz or 5 gigahertz and
there's even a light and a dark theme at
least in the settings I didn't really
find anywhere else that this light and
dark theme affected the OS but the light
and dark theme in the setting is there
and it works and it's pretty awesome
they're not all good tweaks so the one
thing I found that I didn't really like
is the new app drawer in the Google now
launcher it's now a vertically scrolling
spaced-out
alphabetical list of all your apps it
does have a search bar but that's about
the only good thing about it it's a lot
uglier in my opinion than the original
and it is a Developer Preview so in
theory it could be switched back to the
horizontally scrolling alphabetical list
like before but as far as I'm concerned
this is a worse app drawer than we had
previously and hopefully they switch it
back so the number two feature is
something called doze so essentially
what this does is it reads all the
sensors of your phone or tablet stuff
like your gyroscope and accelerometer
and ambient light sensor to determine if
your device is idle and if it sees this
then it will cut down on all the
background activity and all the
background refreshes of your apps to
extend your standby time by a lot and I
love this I love any improvement we can
get to improve the standby time of a
device and hopefully this will bring it
closer to something like you can get on
an iPad sometimes I'll leave an iPad on
a shelf and I'll come back to it a week
later and it still has battery left and
that's never something I've been able to
do with my Nexus 9 for example so
hopefully with doze will seem much
longer much improved standby times for
stuff like tablets and even phones maybe
I'll come back to a phone a couple hours
after I put it up and it'll have plenty
of battery life left so any battery life
improvements are welcome and doze is
great and the number one improvement to
Android M is Google now and Google now
is already a pretty awesome predictive
information service for I mean it has
basically zero competition I mean let's
be honest Siri and Cortana pretty good
voice search assistance but they don't
get anywhere near the level of
functionality of Google now
and yet Google continues to use all the
data they have to make it better and
better as they should this year you know
we get a bunch more cards that are
improved we get a bunch more information
before we even search for it that's the
kind of stuff we're used to with Google
now but now the trick up its sleeve is
something called now on tap so from
anywhere on any screen on your phone you
can hold down the home button to get
Google now cards relevant to whatever is
on your screen unfortunately this is not
working fully in the Developer Preview
but from what we saw in the keynote and
all the demos it looks awesome
essentially maybe you're texting someone
about a business now on tap will let you
hold the home button and get those cards
about maybe a map of where the business
is a shortcut to call them to navigate
there etc it reads what's on your screen
and gives you relevant info let's say
you're on Twitter and you're scrolling
you see a tweet about a new movie you
can tap on long press on that home
button and get info on a nearby movie
theater and info on the ratings and the
actors and everything in the movie
basically it reads what's on your screen
and gives you information that will help
you some might say that's a little bit
creepy and a little bit weird but on the
other hand it's super helpful and
borderline genius so those are your top
features in Android M like I said the
update itself is not a huge visual
change but it's got a bunch of little
tweaks and things and that's not even
the full list I'll leave a link to the
full list of all the improvements of the
Android M Developer Preview we'll
probably see even more tweaks when we
see the final version of Android app
there's even some things that aren't
even specific to the software stuff like
Android pay is new it's got a pretty
familiar name to Apple pay of course but
it's essentially an improved version of
Google Wallet went out with carrier
support now with fingerprint support we
also now have Google Photos Google
Photos app is pretty important it's this
giant archiving backup search and
organizational service for all of your
photos ever and it's free so that's
pretty impressive and should go to
iCloud or run for its money at least for
people who are paying for photo backup
and also a USBC support which should
give us a pretty good idea of what port
to see in the next nexus when it comes
out so there you have it guys that is M
on my Nexus 6 I'm going to continue
using it if I find things like doze
actually improves my battery life I'll
let you guys know
on Twitter and if I find other tweaks
that are helping it out too I'll let you
know and definitely let me know what you
guys think the M stands for in Android M
someone in the comments is going to get
it right it's just a matter of time to
only figure it out what it is either way
if you like this video feel free to
leave a thumbs up below and also further
below there's a subscribe button if you
want to see more videos like this again
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace